Who is she just humor me
Hi my is Grace Helbig  if you do not know, now you know, your life is different now you see the title of this video
It's time for an August favorites. Let's jump right into some of the things that I've liked slightly more than other things this month
Yay first this! CAN YOU SEE IT CAN YOU SEE IT CANT YOU SEE IT starting  off with a cleaning product
That's not a sign that I'm aging, but it matches my lipstick, so these are Clorox  triple action dust wipes
I'm sure you guys have heard of like the Clorox
Wipes that are like have the cleaning
The Clorox wipes that are wet that you can like wipe down I use them to clean everything in my house
But then I found these dust wipes and life has gotten even easier and lazier and better. I'm a dirty dirty
Pigpen human so I get a lot of dust in my house sometimes and when I try using Clorox wipes it just makes wet dust
It feel like dryer sheets and you can just they just get up all the dust and then
It's just on there. Maybe these are just dryer sheets, and I'm being duped but
Advertising works subscribe to my Channel yeah, and you can use these all over your electronics too, and it works wonderfully. That's it next
can you see you can you see it more cleaning products? What have I become, aware of my?
Filth this is actually a whole cleaning kit
That came with like these two spray this like chamois thing and then like a travel chamois
And it's for cleaning your electronics cleaning your computer screens and your phone screens or your iPads or laptops or whatever
It's called iKlear
and clear spelled with a k I got these on Amazon Prime
Just kind of popped up as a recommended thing and I was like yeah to be honest
I don't know if they're the best brand out there, but they work
So I like them when I get on planes and I open up my laptop
That's really when I come to terms with the fact that I'm just a garbage pail kid
There's just dirty fingerprints all over the screen everywhere and like crumbs all in the keyboard I'd become very so conscious of
others realizing
My secret filth and the kit comes with all these little
Travel ones so you can put them just in your bag to have later if you
Are a person that is resourceful and  plans ahead? *pthhh*
What's that like next? This!
Can ya see it can ya see it can ya see it, this is the candle? Oh?
The wax wasn't finished drying. I just became an enrique iglesias music video
Cuz I like this candle so much and I wanted to use it in this video and so the wax wasn't finished drying
And I just got it all over myself
It's the candle I got from Target, and this is on sale for like 12 dollars instead of 15
I guess it doesn't say what the scent is I threw away the thing that says the scent
It says burn within sight keep away from things that catch fire
What great advice oh man it's vine vine what I'm gonna look it up by viney viney
Vineyard Hill Naturals, it's not viney. This is not right. All right. Well this candle smells awesome
It's like a sweet Musk next, This!
Can't see you. Can you see it Can you see it  this is an eyebrow thing from NYX NYX?
Cosmetics it is a three in one
Brow pencil I like finding new products for my eyebrows
I saw this at Target when I got the mystery candle
And I went for it because I like things that are combined into one thing and make it easier for you
So this end has this like brow gel there you go
And then this end has a filler in like little nubby nub open this one
And then the other end here has a smaller little nub enough for like fine little eyebrow line
I thought that was so cool
So I bought it, and I liked it and now I'm telling you next see can you say yeah?
Yeah, say yeah. Yeah, say it these are candy Johnson's new cosmetics that she did with Too Faced and it's called
I want candy I went to her launch party the other night, and they gave us all of our products
And they're so awesome. I love them already. I'm wearing a lot of it right now
I'm wearing this lip color right now
Which is called which sweet and sour I put these kind of lipsticks in favourites videos before because they last forever
They're melted matte the long wear lipstick these all smell like candy
I'm pretty sure I can do I have on her channel a
Big long video explaining in more in depth about all the products if you're interested, but I will say they're awesome
There's this eyeshadow palette look at how pretty all the colors are and they smell they still so sweet
But be careful because if you get you drunk you might you know I say can they eat one of these
This is more of a public service announcement to myself
She's got this like face powder coming out of pudding that smells amazing
And all the packaging is super cute and Candy's just an awesome all around the human being make sure if you were at all
Interested in any of these products you go over to her channel check out her
Instructional video about all of them Congrats candy, and I wish you much success
lovely angel human pixie woman next
This is
This is from a company called serene house
And I think this is like a room diffuser my mom got it for me for Christmas
Good old grace finally check it out of the box in August, but better late than never this thing's really awesome
Mom, thank you. You basically open it up
Oh my god, and then you fill this part with water
And then there's all these essential oils that it comes with that one is called uplifting one's called comforting and one's called
Refreshing, and you just put a few drops of whichever one you want into the water, and then you put the lid back on
Let me plug this thing in give you a demo. Oh you're gonna get a demo
So you put this on and then there's buttons
You can put for on and then look all this smoke comes out and it lights up, and it's looking crazy on camera
But it could it changes colors, and then it infuses your room with these essential oils that are supposed to create miracles
That's not what they advertise. It's cool, and I like it
So there's that serene house is the brand I think my mom got it from Kohl's something like that. Thanks mom, okay?
That's it for this favorites video
Let me know what you guys been enjoying the most this month and make sure you click Subscribe cause I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday except sometimes not those
I don't know
Oooh!
Comforting okay